[Musica]
buon pomeriggio da valter specchio
perché montebelluna sportsystem e perché
dei mega trend suggerite per il mercato
io ho lavorato nello sport per 40 anni
32 li ho passati qui a montebelluna ho
progettato prodotti gli articoli
sportivi per piccole aziende permetti
aziende per grandi gruppi o diretto
dipartimenti di ricerca e sviluppo e
montebelluna è nel cuore poiché questa
occasione di essere qui per terra non
potevo che parlare di montebelluna del
suo sport system perché suggerire dei
mega france perché bisogna avere la
capacità a livello di sistema di
guardare molto avanti quelli cosa sono i
megatrend sono dei trend delle tendenze
socio economiche consolidate
io ne ho scelti 5
potrei dire che ce ne sono una ventina a
livello mondiale
bene nei 105 vediamo quali sono
economia circolare ridurre riusare
ricovero
bene l'economia circolare ci dice che
tutti gli sprechi che noi procuriamo
nelle nostre attività possono essere
impiegati e possono essere possono
creare valore diversamente così facciamo
li buttiamo sotto terra
facciamo un robot due vite possono da
terra oppure ci spacchiamo tutto diamo
fuoco
no ci sono strade ben precise
in questa direzione
noi abbiamo due tipi di rifiuti i
rifiuti biologici e rifiuti biologici
sostanzialmente sono stati affrontati da
anni maniera puntuale e quindi noi
possiamo disperdere nella biosfera acqua
pulita aria pulita elementi di
fertilizzazione del terreno politico gli
altri rifiuti che sono quelli tecnici
hanno bisogno di una cura molto
particolare per cui ecco che allora noi
possiamo pensare di anzitutto di ridurre
l'impiego dei materiali
e qui si apre una grande opportunità per
i progettisti bisogna progettare con la
mentalità nel eco design ma soprattutto
per l'esperienza bisogna progettare con
la logica del disassemblaggio guardate
quanti oggetti che ci sono qui attorno
provate a dese a sembrare questo
televisore ma di sicuro costerà di più
che avevo costruito
di sicuro sarà difficile separare i vari
competitivi quindi parlare di delle 3r
vuol dire all'inizio pensare al ciclo di
vita del prodotto
vuol dire pensare alla culla che fa
nascere questo prodotto al suo degrado e
alla prossima culla che farà nascere
altri prodotti
questo è il messaggio questa può essere
una bandiera futura per il sistema dello
sport system e 5 scelte che ho fatto
sono dedicate allo sport system ii mega
376 s il primo dato è l'aumento della
popolazione mondiale 7.6 2050 e domani
per l'economia 2059 punto 9 miliardi di
persone
la previsione che il 20 per cento di
queste persone
di questi umani sarà over six di fargli
più anziani di 65 anni e ne ho 74 77 4
quindi sono mi rendo perfettamente conto
in quale aria noi dovete pensare che
attualmente in giappone il 26 è più
della per cento della popolazione e
overseas ti fai iniziali siamo vicini al
22 per cento
secondo in questo trend continuerà
perché ma perché le aspettative di vita
è aumentata in questo momento per i
maschietti 80 anni e qualcosa per le
femminucce 85 no continuerà aumentare ma
soprattutto ci sarà un saldo demografico
negativo soprattutto nei paesi
sviluppati le donne fanno meno bambini
ma quale sarà il problema di questi
65enne over 65 anni ma di sicuro molti
di loro hanno problemi di respirazione
di sicuro hanno problemi di mobilità
articolare
sia nelle gambe sia nelle mani come
possiamo noi allora aiutare ma possiamo
fargli fare delle attività motorie di
gruppo perché di gruppo perché l'altra
grande situazioni di disagio una persona
anziana e di sentirsi solo questa
società via buttati da parte in maniera
più o meno conscia non c'è più la casa
del contadino di una volta dove il nonno
la nonna gli zii erano tutti quindi
c'era questo trasferimento di cultura di
esperienza non è più così è una società
così dice atomizzata e quindi
facciamogli fare delle attività motorie
notare camminare non proprio correre
correre correre andare in bicicletta
ballare e diamogli dei prodotti che
siano facili che sia facili da chiude
l'era giacche e siano facili da
indossare
che siano facili da portare perché
questo quello che chiederanno e il
distretto dello sportsystem prepara
altissimo per prendere questo grande
mercato è un mercato di un miliardo di
persone non è una nicchia è un mercato è
uno contorni gradi business 2.1 nel 2050
è un mercato
terzo strand saranno veramente smart se
queste urbanizzazioni ma di sicuro
stiamo vedendo che il dato che più mi ha
impressionato e questo nel 2050 il 72
per cento della popolazione mondiale
vivrà in città
no le città e megalopoli non metropoli
da un milione di abitanti in megalopoli
30 milioni di abitanti più per tokyo
delhi
città del messico è come se noi
prendessimo l'italia che a 60 milioni di
abitanti la divide dalla curva assimo in
due grandi contenitori e da di
stupidissimo 30 milioni da una parte 30
milioni da un'altra voi vedete che la
cina ed india
arriveremo in nei paesi sviluppati
addirittura all 86 per cento di
urbanizzazione
ma cosa potremo fare in questa città
quando si sicuro ci sono due posti
intelligenti il bosco verticale di boeri
e milano è un esempio parigi 2050 è un
altro esempio le città che diventano le
metropoli che incominciano ad interagire
con l'environment cioè con quello che
gli sta attorno e producono conflitto ma
potremmo fare sport in queste città
ricerche di università inglesi hanno
chiaramente dimostrato che chi corre
lungo una strada trafficata e voi li
vedesse annulla completamente i benefici
di quella esercizio fisico e non correte
in fianco alle macchine che corrono ma
in questa metropoli o in queste
metropoli pechino nel 2050
jj 130 milioni di abitanti 100 mila
chilometri quadrati coinvolti collegati
però in maniera velocissima treni che
corrono non più a 300 chilometri all'ora
600 km quindi uscirà il concetto non più
vicina di metropoli di megalopoli
ma il concetto di rete e muoversi
all'interno di questa rete in maniera
efficiente efficace permetterà di aver
accedere a delle zone verdi a delle zone
questo è il futuro non so come l'italia
riuscirà a tagliare questa rete ma
questo è il futuro cosa potrà fare la
sporcizia ma di sicuro che si deve
muovere bisogno di oggetti leggeri di
oggetti che si fa siano facilmente
igienizza bili e soprattutto avrò
bisogno in una città smart dove
l'internet of things cioè l'internet
delle cose le cose che parlano tra di
loro che parlano con te dove
l'intelligenza artificiale artificiale
saranno dominante
abbiamo bisogno di avere la wearable
technology la tecnologia indossabile che
è esplosa in una maniera incredibile nel
recente ispo io ho partecipato a un
convegno di un partecipante un membro
della mia società della mia piattaforma
web silvia europea dello sport e ho
visto 800 progetti mondiali presentarsi
di tecnologie indossabili ormai si può
sapere tutto di voi e con dei costi
molto bassi
mobility questo è un altro treno
questa questa slide mostra il movimento
aereo
attualmente in corso nel 2016 si sono
hanno viaggiato in aereo
un miliardo e 300mila persone e voi
vedete che c'è uno scambio incredibile
fisico perché fisico ma perché le
compagnie low cost hanno dato questa
grande opportunità
e se aggiungiamo a questa nuova e di
vita fisica alla mobilità dei dati
noi possiamo in tempo reale sapere che
cosa succede in questo momento a new
york a pechino
noi possiamo fare una conference call
seduti in macchina al capo del nuovo
bene questa mobilità fisica deve tener
conto tiene conto però dei venti diversi
segmenti della favola del mercato
i millenials muovono si muovono con
logiche diverse degli over sixty file le
persone anziane cercano nella mobilità
turistica sensazioni e fibre
completamente diversi dai giovani
e se io voglio fare attività le piegare
le attività dello sportsystem a questo
mega france ma di sicuro un problema di
salti termici io viaggio molto verso la
cina e quelle zone parto magari qui
d'inverno a zero gradi e arrivo la più
30 gradi però mi è successo anche al
contrario di accertamento ha nevicato in
un posto così qui ero andato via con
aver voluto tutto bello leggerino invece
si è messo a nevicare che quando uscì
dalla
da questa dal taxi e feci così col naso
perché noi sentiamo il motore della neve
lo sapete no e lì si qui nevica e questi
si misero ridono mai navigato dopo un
quarto d'ora eravamo al taipei
ok io ero con i calzoncini corti e qui
sono dovuto correre prendervi qualcosa
allora se avessi avuto invece una
attrezzatura scarpe abbigliamento perché
era aggiustabile se mi potessi coprire
come una cipolla e come nazione che ti
danno quando vai in in inghilterra
quando sai di fronte a quella l'oceano
atlantico copriti scoppio perché in
questo momento piove dopo viene il sole
dopo cena e questo è un altro tema chi
viaggia a dei problemi
lo stesso vuole oggetti leggeri facili
facilmente incendiabili e vuole essere
rete collegato con l'amico obesi fa la
slide che vedete non quella sinistra che
dice che non potete più mangiare il
gelato alla fragola perché quello che vi
fa diventare obesi
ok non è così ma questi sono i miei
studenti all'università che fanno queste
presentazioni e io li lascio fare perché
siete facessi io da un vecchiaccio di 74
anni proventi fare delle cose molto
seriosa e pallose 20 sono i miei ragazzi
i dati che vedete sono del 2012
non è vero
in questo momento ci sono 500mila obesi
se sono già 600 mila
non è vero che ci sono sovrappeso un
miliardo e cinquecento mila persone
c'è un miliardo e 900 mila persone io
sono obeso o sovrappeso
usiamo un premio che si chiama via e mai
emesse ti dice da documenti il tuo peso
e lo dvd per il quadrato della pena tua
età
ne esce un numero sotto il 20 56
normopeso
dovrei pesare 74 qui nel peso 81 fra 25
e 36 sovrappeso oltre il 36 o obeso bene
cosa possiamo fare per questi mani soli
gli obesi hanno dei problemi notevoli
il primo problema è quella della p
le sofferenze che il sistema cuore
polmone porta per portare avanti queste
must e gli possiamo fare farle delle
attività motorie
certo che sì anche questi sembrano delle
attività motorie non invasive
dovremo soprattutto proteggere gli arti
inferiori
tendenzialmente l'obesità porta ad avere
le ginocchia le gambe alix e levigatura
una pronazione del piede all'esterno
quindi ci dovrà essere un grande cura
in questa direzione dal punto di vista è
ancora una volta lo so sport system è in
grado di rispondere in pieno a questa
situazione vecchio vero ma ci vogliono
[Applauso]